hey how's it going bros my name is Baron
ah almost exactly one year ago I
uploaded a video title goodbye forever a
comments so dramatic yes I basically
explained in this video that I was going
to turn up the comments and they're
never coming back now this video got a
lot of attention I think the main reason
behind it was because so many people
could relate to it the comments on
YouTube was insanely bad the system was
so easy to exploit that people were
using it to advertise their own channels
advertise other websites spreading
viruses impersonating me I had to turn
it off because I literally had no other
choice I couldn't like that keep going a
lot of people seem to think I did it
because I couldn't handle the hate but I
don't know I explained it clearly in the
video but as you can probably tell
comments are back up hallelujah
they fixed it yes no not really actually
they improved a lot but it still has a
long way to go and that's why I'm making
this video because I need you bros help
basically if you go to one of my videos
you will find oh look at that
it's me oh look at that I am telling
people to go to whatever the [ __ ] that
is first of all why can you link to
other websites in the comments who the
[ __ ] thought that was a good idea second
of all why can someone else person
impersonate me completely
who the [ __ ] thought that was a good
idea that you can name yourself whatever
you want on YouTube you could not do
that before the Google Plus update
either way these guys are spreading
Rises don't click on them so I'm gonna
show you how you know if it's not me or
not basically if you mouse over my name
or my icon this little banner will
appear and it will say subscribe and
then the zero next to it which basically
means is not me because it has zero
subscribers if it's me it will look like
this
and if you mouse over it it will say 38
million subscribers great that's how you
know this was not a thing before so I'm
glad they added that if you ever see one
of these please thumb it down hover over
in the right corner report spam and
abuse unwanted advertising in Kaunas
vent continue okay great I wanted to
turn the comments back on as an
experiment and see if it's possible to
keep them on without spam and viruses
and all that crap I suggested to Google
long time ago that you could have
moderators in this shed because I'm sure
so many of your brothers would more than
would be more than happy to help out I
don't think a youtuber or a content
creators time should be spent moderating
the shat because there's not enough time
for one person to do that it's just
impossible I don't understand why not
there's so many things about this that I
don't understand and I know it might
seem very silly to you I'm making such a
big deal out of the comments but to be
fair it's the main thing I have for you
bros is my main connection with you and
I want to keep that I want to keep that
flowing and that's why I want the
comments to be about the video or
something related in general because I
want you bros feedback and I really do
appreciate getting it I don't just
ignore the comments or just like up up
video is up I'll just go and take a [ __ ]
I don't know I've probably done that a
couple of times if you could help me out
I very much appreciate it and thank you
both for keep showing your feedback and
support I really really do appreciate it
so I'll see you in the next video and
we'll see how this goes as always stay
awesome bros